let's say if you get a divorce would you
consider that as defeat yes yeah yeah
you should be upset
i am divorced that that's a ding on my
record that that is a failure i failed i
mean he also failed you know i've not
been out of shape about it because i got
the man in my dreams but you should
look at divorce as a failure i don't
know why you wouldn't yeah you chose
poorly and now you've wasted each
other's time interesting interesting
would you say it's a failure if you were
um able to
give birth to children and like your
children ended up in like a good place
and they have a successful future no
it's still a failure it's beautiful that
the children are here most parents don't
regret their kids that innately
but it is still a failure you chose
poorly you reproduce now these children
don't have a father in the home but
we're so used to it we think that it's
okay but the outcomes are still negative
like i grew up in a single mother home i
i had a lot of risk factors that i had
to solve myself in the dating market and
that's something that doesn't get talked
about it's all about this eat pray love